G
US, I AM TREY GOWDY, IT'S
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
BORDER SECURITY AND
IMMIGRATION ARE FEDERAL
ISSUES, IMMIGRATION IS
MENTIONED IN THE
CONSTITUTION, 17 STATES
SHARE A BORDER WITH ANOTHER
COUNTRY, WE CAN'T HAVE 50
DIFFERENT IMMIGRATION POLICY
AND 17 DIFFERENT APPROACHES
TO BORDER SECURITY.
BUT WHAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ISN'T DOING ITS
JOB.
WHAT IS THE BORDER ISN'T
SECURE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T FOLLOW
ITS OWN LAWS, IT IS
SMUGGLERS, AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND DRUGS AND
WEAPONS AND TERRORISM ALSO
PEOPLE HERE UNLAWFULLY
COMMITTING SERIOUSLY, DEADLY
CRIMES, SOVEREIGN NATIONS
NEED SECURE BORDERS.
STRONG COUNTRIES ENFORCE
THEIR LAW ANDS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO ITS
JOB OR SOMEONE ELSE WILL.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND RON
DESANTIS ARE HIGHLIGHTING
THESE ISSUES, THERE ARE NOW
THREATS TO SUE GOVERNORS AND
CALLS FOR CRIMINAL PROBES.
SOMEONE REMOVED GOVERNORS
FROM OFFICE BUT NOT REMOVE
PEOPLE HERE UNLAWFULLY?
JOINING US NOW IS FORMER DHS
SECRETARY CHAD WOLF THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US, YOUR
SUCCESSOR SAID THAT BORDER
IS SECURE HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE IT.
>> THE BORDER IS ANYTHING
BUT SECURE, WE CONTINUE TO
SEE MONTH AFTER MONTH HIGH
NUMBERS OVER 200 THOUSAND
ILLEGAL APPREHENSIONS OVER
900,000 GOT AWAYS THIS
FISCAL YEAR THAT IS ENDING
IN ABOUT A MONTH FROM NOW,
WITH THAT MUCH UNLAWFUL AND
UNCONTROLLED MIGRATION
ACROSS THE SORT OF EVERYONE
BORDER YOU HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER IT YOU COULD POINT TO A
COUPLE OTHER NUMBERS,
NUMBERS OF KNOWN AND
SUSPECTED TERRORISTS THEY
ARE APPREHENDING AT THAT
BORDER IS GOING UP EACH AND
EVERY MONTH.
12 ALONE IN THE MONTH OF
AUGUST ALONE.
THE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GET
WORSE WITH BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE NOT
DOING ONE FUNDAMENTAL THING
THAT IS ENFORCING THE LAW
AND BRINGING DETERRENTS WHO
THE SYSTEM, IF INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT AFRAID OF GETTING
CAUGHT, YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE THE NUMBERS THAT WE DO
EVERY DAY.
TREY: YOU ARE A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS DO,
GOVERNORS LIKE GREG ABBOTT
AND RON DESANTIS HAVE TO
TAKE MIGRANTS SENT TO THEIR
STATE OR DO THEY HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY TO SAY NOT HERE OR
NOT NOW?
>> AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, IT IS
COMPLICATED, FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THE ABILITY
IF THE MIGRANTS ARE IN THEIR
CUSTODY TO ABOVE THE
MIGRANTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY, THE QUESTION, LIKE
IN STATE OF TEXAS DHS RUNS
OUT OF BED SPACE AND
SHELTERS TO HOUSE THE
MIGRANTS, THEY RELEASE THEM
ON TO THE STREETS OF EL PASO
OR BROWNSVILLE, WHAT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS SAYING
NOWS ARE NOT SAFE BUJUST
SLEEPING ON CITY STREETS
WE'LL BUS THEM TO NEW YORK
AND CHICAGO AND DC AND
ELSEWHERE BECAUSE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS WASHED THEIR
HANDS OF THE MATTER.
TREY: THIS WEEK.
WE COULD HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ANY WEEK.
TWO MORE VIOLENT CRIMES
ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED BY MEN
UNLAWFULLY IN THE COUNTRY,
HOW HAS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATIONA REMOVAL
PROCESS DIFFERENT FROM WHEN
YOU WERE RUNNING THE SHOW.
>> EVERYTHING IS DIFFERENT,
THEY ARE REMOVING LESS AND
LESS INDIVIDUALS, I THINK
THEY ARE IN AN IS
TIME LOW IN AMOUNT OF
INDIVIDUALS THEY ARE
TARGETING AND
ARRESTS, WE ALLOWED I.C.E.
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOBS,
WE FOCUSED ON THE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS, WE ALSO SAID, IF
YOU ARE GOING INTO A STASH
HOUSE, AND YOU ARE TARGETING
AND PICKING UP A VIOLENT
INDIVIDUAL, IF THERE ARE 20
OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
THERE THAT ARE ILLEGAL, YOU
CAN PICK THEM UP TOO, BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAID YOU CAN
ONLY PICK UP THE ONE
INDIVIDUAL, YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE THE OTHER 19 OR 20
THERE, THAT IS WHY YOU SEE
THE NUMBERS OF REMOVAL OUT
OF THE UNITED STATES AS AN
ALL IS TIME LOW.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DON'T LIKE TO ENDORSE BORDER
SECURITY OR IMMIGRATION LAW.
TREY: ALL RIGHT, WE GOT 30
SECONDS.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
WAS PUT IN CHARGE OF THE
ROOT CAUSES OF MIGRATION.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT IS
GOING?
>> I THINK SHE HAS BEEN A
DISASTER, NOT ONLY FOR ROOT
CAUSES BUT SHE IS A BORDER
CZAR, NOT SURE WHAT HER JOB
IS AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
KNOW THAT INDIVIDUALS FROM
CENTRAL MEXICO, CENTRAL
AMERICA, AND MEXICO, ARE
ABOUT 35 TO 39% OF THE
INDIVIDUALS COMES ACROSS THE
BORDER, IF SHE WANTS TO
FOCUS ON ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION SHY IS
TACKLING ONLY 45% OF THE
PROBLEM YOU HAVE THOUSAND
COMING FROM DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES THEY KNOW.
THAT THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN
AND THERE IS VERY LITTLE
CONTROL OVER IT TODAY.
TREY: CHAD WOLF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE, HARD JOB,
I APPRECIATE Y